bien enfin
y a-t-il des professionnels de santé
dans la salle
oui quelques-uns
alors je m'adresse à tout le monde
pensez-vous qu'un diabète qu'une
insuffisance cardiaque qu'un cancer
qu'une polyarthrite puisse être
secondaire à des violences conjugales
la réponse est oui
on a prouvé depuis 1998
que toutes les pathologies que je viens
de citer surviennent plus fréquemment
chez les personnes qui ont subi un ou
plusieurs psychotraumatismes
le psychotroma qu'est-ce que c'est c'est
quand on a le sentiment que la mort est
imminente pour soi ou pour son entourage
comme par exemple dans un attentat
lorsqu'on est victime ou témoin d'un
attentat
pourquoi parce que notre cerveau n'est
pas programmé pour vivre de telles
violences en fait le psychothuma
survient quand on a des situations de
violence intenses extrêmes pour lesquels
nous ne sommes pas préparés ni
programmer ça n'est pas dans nos gènes
quand une antilope ou une gazelle va
boire au Marigot
elle est programmée pour avoir peur d'un
lion qui s'approche d'elle en revanche
quand un individu va Reims prendre une
coupe de champagne à la terrasse d'un
café il n'est pas programmé pour se
faire poignarder par un autre humain
notre cerveau ne connaît pas cela ce
n'est pas dans ces dans son histoire
dans ces dans sa dans ses possibles
alors que se passe-t-il justement dans
notre cerveau en cas d'attentat nous
sommes le 13 novembre 2015 je me promène
à Paris on passe devant le Bataclan au
moment des attentats
mon cerveau perçoit l'extrême danger et
immédiatement sans comprendre ce qu'il
se passe
va m'inonder d'hormones de stress et
d'adrénaline
je vais stresser je vais avoir le cœur
qui palpite je vais avoir extrêmement
peur de mourir
mon cerveau qui ne comprend absolument
pas la situation ce n'est pas inscrit
dans cette possible quand je me promène
dans Paris je ne suis pas
m'attend pas à avoir un attentat de
temps en temps continuer à m'inonder
d'hormones de stress à tel point que je
vais finir par en mourir par défaillance
cardiaque ou pas des nécrose du cerveau
à cause de ces hormones alors comme la
nature est bien faite mon cerveau va me
préserver va se protéger en disjonctant
il va couper le courant il va stopper
les flux d'hormones
de manière à ce que tout à coup je me
sens zen
tranquille
détendu je n'ai plus de douleur je n'ai
plus de peur j'ai même l'impression de
sortir de mon corps et de voir mon corps
blessé sans aucune douleur je suis en
anesthésie émotionnelle je suis
totalement dissociée du contexte
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'on appelle la
dissociation traumatique c'est
dissociations on la retrouve chez les
femmes victimes de viol qui ont l'air de
se laisser faire d'être passive c'est
tout au moins ce que va dire l'avocat du
violeur en disant bah elle était
consentante c'était un accord tacite
alors que non une femme qui subit un
viol si elle reste passive ce n'est pas
un consentement c'est parce qu'elle est
dissociée pour survivre
son cerveau a coupé les flux d'hormones
de manière à ce qu'elle ne meurt pas
dans la dissociation l'événement passe
en mémoire dans un mauvais endroit du
cerveau ce qu'on appelle la mémoire
traumatique cette mémoire traumatique
elle est totalement ingérable
elle vous envoie des idées flash des
pensées intrusives des idées absolument
horribles des images horribles des
cauchemars qui vont vous mettre dans un
état de stress intense de panique de
façon totalement inopinée impromptu
comme ça baladé puis tout à coup pas
vous vous retrouvez dans un état de
stress comme jour de l'attentat
pour éviter ces attaques de stress et de
panique vous allez éviter toutes les
situations qui pourraient vous évoquer
un tant soit peu l'événement traumatique
vous n'y passez vous ne passerez plus
devant le Bataclan vous n'irez plus
boire une coupe de champagne à la
terrasse d'un café à Reims
cette mémoire traumatique totalement
ingérable que vous ne pouvez pas gérer
ne va pas s'estomper avec le temps la
bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'on peut la guérir pas seul
c'est-à-dire que vous malgré la plus
grande force mentales du monde vous ne
pouvez pas gérer votre cerveau fait ce
qu'il veut
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on peut
traiter en faisant des psychothérapies
adaptés au psychotrope donc il y en a
pas mal elles sont toutes efficaces le
mdr l'hypnose etc qui vont avoir comme
mission de ranger cette mémoire
traumatique qui est au mauvais endroit
dans le bon endroit du cerveau là où il
y a tous les autres souvenirs
c'est conduite des vêtements et tout ça
donc ne vont pas s'estomper tout seul
sans un traitement
elles vont
de psychotroma la mémoire
traumatique donc pourquoi cela entraîne
en plus de toutes les phénomènes de
psychologiques que je viens de citer des
maladies chroniques
il y a deux raisons qui expliquent ces
phénomènes la première raison c'est la
baisse de l'immunité de la capacité à se
défendre croire que donner une claque à
un enfant va l'endurcir on va le
renforcer et totalement faux
quand on frappe quelqu'un plus on le
frappe plus on l'affaiblit dans un match
de boxe le boxeur qui prend le plus de
coûts celui qui s'affaiblit et qui va
perdre le match une victime de violence
plus elle subit des violences qu'elle
soit physique ou psychologiques plus
elle s'affaiblit tu elle devient
perméable accessible aux agressions de
l'agresseur bien entendu mais aux
agressions extérieures comme les
infections les maladies chroniques
la deuxième raison qui est plus
étonnante encore c'est que il y a des
modifications génétiques
nos gènes peuvent se modifier en
fonction de notre environnement ou de
notre face de notre façon de vivre par
exemple si vous partez de Reims demain
pour aller vivre à 4000 mètres
d'altitude dans la montagne vos gènes
vont se modifier légèrement pour vous
permettre de vous adapter à ce nouvel
environnement vous serez plus résistant
à l'altitude au manque d'oxygène au
froid et peut-être même que vous aurez
une appétence plus marquée pour le vin
chaud plutôt que le champagne mais ça je
pense pas
donc c'est phénomène de modification
génétique qu'on appelle épigénétique
il a été prouvé scientifiquement
biologiquement que le psychotraumatisme
les psychotraumatisme entraîné des
modifications génétiques épigénétiques
qui peuvent favoriser la survenue de
pathologies inflammatoires auto-immune
cancéreuse hormonale donc des maladies
chroniques
la bonne nouvelle parce que je n'apporte
pas que des mauvaises nouvelles j'espère
la bonne nouvelle c'est que ces
modifications génétiques sont
réversibles c'est à dire qu'en changeant
l'environnement de nouveau on peut
changer l'écriture de ces gènes et en
faisant disparaître le climat de
violence en traitant le
psycho-traumatisme on a des réparations
des gènes et donc des disparitions de
ces modifications
donc
pour les professionnels de santé mais en
fait pour tout le monde il faut poser la
question des violences à des personnes
qui souffrent de maladies chroniques
parce que si ces personnes ont eu la
chance entre guillemets j'entends
d'avoir vécu des violences qui peuvent
être la cause de ces maladies en
traitant l'environnement violent en
traitant le psychotromatisme on va
traiter et guérir ces maladies
chroniques que sont le diabète le cancer
etc
c'est étonnant
mais c'est vrai je vais tester ça marche
sans traitement
donc les traitements comme elles
enthalgiques les anti-inflammatoires
anxiolytiques antidépresseurs sont les
traitements symptomatiques qui vont
traiter les symptômes c'est très
important mais qui ne vont pas traiter
et guérir la maladie puisqu'il ne traite
pas la cause
alors posez la question c'est bien c'est
mais il faut aussi être en aptitude à
recevoir la réponse et aussi à
reconnaître que la victime est une
victime et le reconnaître soi-même mais
aussi le faire reconnaître à la victime
et pour cela il faut avant tout changer
son regard
alors sur votre gauche vous avez des
victimes de violence de guerre ou
d'attentat sur votre doigt de droite les
victimes de violences conjugales il
existe une seule différence entre ces
deux victimes
notre regard
notre regard qui nous dit que la victime
de gauche d'attentat de guerre sont
totalement innocentes alors que les
victimes de violences conjugales
sont peut-être un peu responsables de ce
qui leur arrive peut-être même un peu
coupable on a tous dit oui mais oui mais
pourquoi ne s'en va-t-elle pas pourquoi
reste-t-elle avec lui pourquoi pourquoi
était-elle dans cette situation dans ce
soir là etc pourquoi il était à
l'habiller comme ça on a tous dit oui
mais comme si il fallait donner une
justification au fait d'être victime
les victimes de violences conjugales les
victimes de viol les victimes de
harcèlement les victimes d'incestes sont
toutes des victimes à part entière elles
n'ont aucune responsabilité dans ce qui
leur arrive elles sont simplement au
mauvais endroit au mauvais moment comme
les victimes d'attentat
changer son regard ça n'est pas si
facile ce dotant que les victimes de
violence souvent se culpabilisent
elles-mêmes d'être dans cette situation
et souvent même minimise les violences
qu'elles subissent
pourquoi
parce qu'elles ont honte
elles ont honte d'être victime de
violence de viol
parce que c'est honteux et pourquoi
parce que elle porte le même regard que
le nôtre sur les victimes de violence
faites aux femmes ce regard
culpabilisant donc il faut
les aider à se reconnaître comme victime
car c'est la première pierre de la
reconstruction se reconnaître comme
victime c'est reconnu par la société
comme victime et donc il faut les aider
avec empathie bienveillance
à se reconnaître comme victime
donc demain vous toutes et tous quel que
soit votre profession même si ce n'est
pas dans la santé tout le monde tout
citoyen vous avez le pouvoir quel que
soit vos connaissances en psychotrauma
vous avez le pouvoir d'aider ces
victimes de les guérir de participer à
leur guérison en disant
juste quelques phrases
si vous avez qu'une à retenir c'est je
te crois où je vous crois
vous n'êtes pas là pour porter du
jugement vous croyez
vous n'êtes pas responsable de ce qui
vous arrive
seul l'agresseur est responsable et les
violences qu'il vous a fait subir sont
punis par la loi par la société ça n'est
pas la vie normale c'est violence et oui
on peut s'en sortir ça n'est pas
irrémédiable seul c'est quasi impossible
mais avec l'aide des associations avec
l'aide des psychothérapies adaptés aux
psychotroma oui on peut s'en sortir
conclusion retenez tous et tous que vous
avez ce pouvoir en vous d'aider à la
reconstruction à la guérison et par la
même à guérir certaines maladies
chroniques
donc pour leur bien pour le vôtre aussi
faites le
sauver les
et enfin puisqu'il me reste peut-être
une minute j'aimerais m'adresser à
toutes les victimes qui sont dans cette
salle et il y en a 20%
environ qui ont subi des violences
graves ne croyez pas que le traumatisme
va s'estomper avec le temps
si vous avez encore des stress
inexpliqués des cauchemars des idées
intrusives ça n'est pas de la folie
c'est votre mémoire traumatique qui vous
fait souffrir
seul vous n'arriverez jamais à la gérer
c'est comme ça
il faut vous faire aider avec de l'aide
ou oui vous avez le pouvoir de faire
quelque chose
une seule chose qui n'est pas facile
mais que vous pouvez faire il faut
prendre le temps d'y penser
prendre votre temps pour vous lancer
dans pour sortir de cette influence du
silence qui règne autour de vous en tant
que victime c'est de libérer votre
parole même si le traumatisme est très
ancien je vous ai dit que ça continue
tout le temps tout le temps même si ça
vous paraît pas si grave que ça
en libérant votre parole vous allez
améliorer votre santé
probablement guérir certaines maladies
chroniques donc
osez le faire n'ayez pas peur de parler
prenez le temps qu'il faut mais libérez
votre parole
[Applaudissements]